i just finished watching the season last
night the two of you are so good in the
show
i was clamoring to find out like more
mysteries i had to stop myself from
trying to pick andrew's brain um
but i'm curious for the two of you how
familiar were you with the resident evil
franchise before you signed on to this
show i was coming into this completely
fresh i actually didn't know about the
the franchise and how big it was
but i did watch a bunch of people
playing the video games so i could
familiarize myself
i was very nervous auditioning though i
do remember that and i was like oh you
know whatever happens happens but this
is huge yeah i would agree we kind of
just started on the same level which i
think was important because it just
meant we went in the same kind of
knowledge and yeah we were both very
nervous about it coming in with fresh
characters and you know it means a lot
to people and it's
it's nerve-wracking kind of coming into
that because
you know you don't want to intrude or
anything and it's joining this massive
franchise and because we're coming out i
think we got lucky because we came in
with fresh characters and so it means
you can mold it into the storyline which
was we got really lucky with but um
yeah we we um
we really enjoyed kind of working
together especially just because it's
we're on the same level yeah i
definitely want to ask you about the
casting process and what that was like
did the two of you get a chance to read
off of each other were there kind of
sister chemistry tests like how did all
of that pan out
usually usually there are
but this casting process was just a bit
different
um at least for me i remember i first
auditioned for jade
i didn't i didn't it didn't work for me
and then they came back the next day and
then they said they gave me the audition
for billy
and
i sent in a self tape
and then i heard that i was in the mix
january or february of 2020
and i
booked it officially in november and we
started filming in january so it was all
it was all it was spread out throughout
a whole year but it's very exciting very
nerve-wracking yeah okay so i auditioned
for jade and then i auditioned for billy
and they were like this is wrong so then
i auditioned for jade again
um and then i found out i was in the
running and then i found out i got the
part um
[Music]
but it was
it was so much fun honestly it was
it was really interesting because
we kind of just got to
really
get to know the characters i think and
that was really important and i think
that
what also was important was that
we
were we kind of got this fresh start
which we wouldn't have gotten if we had
done a screen test which was really
interesting
and also when we were put in
that kind of last minute moment in the
characters in the set it kind of worked
really well and so i think we got really
lucky with that that's true we did like
work on a lot of development for our
characters before we even work together
yeah and so then we just kind of got to
get there
[Laughter]
um the relationship between billy and
jade is obviously complicated but also
very close-knit i feel like i already
know the answer to this question just
seeing the two of you right now
interacting in front of me but did the
two of you do anything kind of offset or
off camera to really grow the dynamic
that we see on the show
no not really okay
we just was separate the whole time
yeah um no we were together so much
stuff almost we went to like
we went to a safari we went horse riding
we went surfing
we went to bogening
[Music]
we went to small stores sand boarding
sand duning
and we got to yeah each other pretty
well um
especially in the beginning that was
really important to us to just like
spend that kind of time together and
develop it but you know honestly i feel
like a lot of our relationship
development was on and off takes yeah
because you you
were so vulnerable in the scene and then
you step off of set and you're still in
that vulnerability and there's so much
power of bonding with someone in that
moment oh yeah definitely definitely i
would completely agree and yeah i would
just agree certain some like in between
scenes would just like get to know each
other more which is
like what's your favorite color okay
actually now we're crying again i think
the two of you have a really unique
because you're in a unique position
because the both of you
are playing characters that are also
played by different actresses in in the
future version of themselves um i'm
wondering how collaborative that process
was for the four of you did you have a
chance to kind of work with
the actresses playing the older sisters
you know work out any similarities and
what you wanted to kind of bring to
those characters
yeah so we didn't have a lot of time
because of just the fact that our
schedules were completely opposite um
and so it was really hard to kind of
figure out times when we could do that
but the first couple of weeks were
really light so we got lucky with that
and then kind of just started working
together
and
just to create those just tiny
similarities um in just certain
mannerisms and like just the way that we
would say things or lines or the way
that you would hold someone
and so we both kind of just did that
sienna with adeline and i with them
ella but it was just really important
for us to have that because the
the timelines are so so starkly
different
and we didn't want to make it so obvious
that it was like they're trying but not
not not enough that it was like they
don't look they don't even like act the
same you know yeah
we we didn't since we didn't have much
time like the times that we were
together
we definitely tried to get as much out
of it um
and try to spend as much time
you know getting to know each other yeah
i don't think it's inaccurate to say
that a huge theme of this show is family
and one of the things i
i really loved about this show
specifically is how
the wesker family dynamic again is just
so complex has so many different layers
and also becomes more complicated the
more that these girls are looking into
what their father is actually doing at
umbrella i spoke with lance a little bit
about it earlier today but i would love
to get your take on just figuring out
that dynamic with him working with him
what he's like as a scene partner that
kind of thing
lance is incredible he's so well
respected in the industry and such an
incredible actor but like just watching
him work and being around that and being
in a scene with him and having that
opportunity to just work off of an actor
like him
was just so inspiring
um and yeah for him to play our dad like
that
you know you dream of working with
someone like that so
he taught us a lot on and offset took
care of us and
it really helped working with such
talented actors
you got to just play off of each other
and find something new in each take
yeah and i thought i think what really
really helped was the fact that kind of
we were just kind of put in south africa
and so just by chance like the universe
kind of pushed us together as a family
because you're missing your own family
um and we were there for six months and
so we were just making those connections
because it's like i'm gonna be away for
a while and so i'll make these
connections and you just get to know
people more even just like with the crew
um
it just kind of happened because you
just
you're just surrounded by these people
and you get to know them and you make
these connections and they just become
really important to you there are a ton
of i would say very intense scenes not
just on an emotional level but a
physical level as well but is there any
that stands out particularly in your
mind i'm sure you can't say spoilers you
go into spoiler territory but anything
that was particularly challenging to
film this season whether it was a scene
together or a part
yeah for me that was one scene um
it was
um
this is hard yeah you know which scene
i'm talking about okay there's a scene
that we're both in that's definitely
spoiler territory but we won't we won't
go into it but it was definitely
physically demanding but we trained on
and off set and we worked with the stunt
team and they made it quite a different
scene what
so there's a scene for me which is
really hard
um which is really distressing
and we filmed it for about three days
never mind but anyways i've seen that
scene i found is really hard um
because i i was crying in it and i was
screaming and i was like crying and
screaming for about three days i lost my
voice i yeah it was a lot it was a lot a
lot but um
it was so worth it watching that back
was insane yeah i feel like a lot is a
great way to describe this show in a
good way yeah
but on that note i'm actually all at a
time but thank you both so much for
taking the time to sit and chat with me
about this show it was great to see the
two of you getting to play sisters this
season and i am already crossing my
fingers that we'll get to see another
season of that so thank you
thank you so much